[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK CALDWELL: Hey, everybody.
Welcome to "Predicting
Community Engagement
on Reddit Using TensorFlow,
GDELT, and Cloud Dataflow."
If that's the session
you're looking for,
you are in the correct place.
Who am I?
My name is Nick Caldwell.
Actually, I'll introduce
my nonprofit first
to get that out of the way.
I'm a board member
of a nonprofit called
Dev Color, whose goal is
to advance people of color
into leadership
positions in technology.
And then maybe perhaps more
interesting to most folks
in the room, I'm also VP of
engineering here at Reddit.
And yeah.
Reddit fans in the audience?
OK, there we go.
So it sounds like
a lot of you guys
know what Reddit is already.
For those of you who don't,
I'll do a quick intro.
Reddit is the front
page of the internet.
That's how the outside
world thinks about us.
But inside Reddit, we
think about ourselves
a little bit more in
terms of community.
So we say we're a
social network where
there are tens of thousands
of communities around whatever
passions or interests
you might have,
where people converse
about the things that
are most important to them.
For those of you
who know what Reddit
is, you may not know
some of these statistics
I'm about to throw at you.
Reddit is, I would say,
kind of a big deal--
fourth largest site
in the United States,
according to Alexa, sixth
largest in the world,
350 million monthly
active users,
10.7 million posts per month,
2.8 million comments per day,
58 million votes per day.
And then getting back to
the theme of communities,
more than one million
communities on the site.
And when we think about
communities this year,
particularly 2018,
Reddit is really
trying to transform itself
in the following way.
We want to be able
to connect people
to the best, most interesting
communities for them.
For those of you
in the audience who
have been on Reddit
for a long time,
one question I often ask
our users is how long did it
take for you to find
your first community?
For me, that was
about four years.
We're trying to get that
number down to maybe
a few minutes, would be great.
So Reddit is this vast
network of communities-- news,
politics, gaming, sports, all
sorts of different content
we've tried to visualize here.
And the question we've
been wrestling with
is how do we connect people
with the right communities?
Now, later on, you're
going to hear from Sergei,
and he's going to
talk about some
really, really advanced
techniques and recommendations.
But I thought as a cue
into that discussion,
perhaps we could take
a trip down memory lane
and talk about the history
of Reddit's data platform,
if you will indulge me.
So I'll start in
2006, the dark ages,
trying to solve this problem of
recommending content to users.
Our first approach was
collaborative filtering.
The way Reddit works, for
those of you have seen it,
we have a system of up
votes and down votes.
So one might naturally
think that if you
have the same up voting, down
voting pattern as someone
else on the site, perhaps you
would recommend similar things
to each other.
And this was state
of the art for 2006.
We represented users
as a matrix with posts
in what they voted on.
We used cosine
similarity distance,
recentered by subtracting
the global mean,
and then applied SVD
to get the results.
Now, great for 2006.
It turns out it
just doesn't work.
We had a couple problems that
we were trying to overcome,
data sparseness.
You may not realize it
now, but back in 2006,
Reddit didn't even
have communities.
It was just one
front page listing,
one big pile of content.
So not a lot of interesting
dimensions to look at.
The median number of votes
per user was pretty much one.
So very few people
actually voting.
And this meant that if you have
the combination of everything
only showing up on one page
with very few people voting,
you really get
this mean response
behavior, where you're
just recommending
the same stuff to everybody.
And we had no feedback loop
on that except for-- this is
an example we've taken
from nine years ago--
why does the recommended
feature suck so bad?
I routinely down vote every
American politics story.
My first two recommended pages
are nothing but politics.
OK.
But there was a
use case for this,
if you can imagine,
vote cheating.
So what is vote cheating?
Let me explain why
you would do this.
Reddit, if you can get your
content to the front page,
it's actually pretty valuable.
Several million people
are going to see that.
So to cheat Reddit
back in the day,
create a bunch of bot
accounts, have them all up vote
your content, and profit.
And it turns out that these
bots, these cheating accounts,
also have very, very
similar voting patterns.
You can actually make a
visualization of that.
This is clusters of people
who have similar voting
behavior on the site.
And you can see
that in the center,
there is the standard behavior,
a lot of mean response voting
behavior.
But you can see islands of these
unique users off to the side.
And these are cheaters.
So we did find a
way to use that.
Now, from 2008 to
2014, for those of you
who understand
Reddit's history, we'll
call this the
dramatic intermission.
Nothing really happened on
Reddit from a data perspective,
but the site did
continue to grow.
One great advantage
of working at Reddit
is the site is just addictive.
We call it weaponized
procrastination.
And it will grow
in and of itself.
So between 2008, 2014,
it's growing by itself.
But then the gears start to
come back into motion in 2014.
This is Reddit's first real
data and analytics pipeline.
Everything previous to this was
essentially just a lot of data
from logs sitting in Postgres.
Here we've got Kafka
dumping data in S3,
being processed by Hive.
And as you can
imagine, for those
of you who have dealt with
Hive, this is kind of slow.
It's not really operational.
Really what this got used
for was every two months,
Reddit has a board meeting and
the deck needs to be created.
So someone would go
kick the Hive jobs
and generate the board deck.
But it's better than nothing.
2015, we start to get just a
little bit more sophisticated.
We added Midas.
For those of you
who know, that's
an open source project
that does enrichment.
We used it to enrich
geolocation, user agent data,
et cetera.
Another year goes by.
We're starting to get a little
bit more interesting here.
This is when we can finally
do relevance and feedback.
We've got two services here,
the blue and yellow one.
Minsky, for those of you
folks who are into classic AI,
Minsky's named
after Marvin Minsky.
And this is essentially
our first attempt
at allowing the home page
to be generated dynamically
based on user
preference, and we'll
talk about that a
little bit more later.
On the second box is Spamurai.
And what that is is it uses
hand tuned rules in conjunction
with feedback from
the community in order
to try and dynamically
detect spam.
And this is really
important because this
is the first feedback loop
that takes data analytics
and drives it back
into the product.
2017, which
effectively brings us
very close to our
present-day system,
we began forking all
of our event data
into BigQuery after
considering a lot
of different alternatives.
For those of you who
are considering this,
I highly recommend it.
Coincidentally, that's why
they invited me to talk here.
[LAUGHS]
But BigQuery is actually
pretty freaking good.
It's simpler to manage.
It's got much faster
query performance.
You can connect it to
a host of BI tools.
We use Mode Looker or Power BI.
And on top of all that,
it's pretty freaking cheap,
which makes our COO very happy.
So we can't say this
is a perfect solution.
I do have some
complaints about it,
but I don't really lose sleep
over thinking about our data
warehouse choices anymore.
So with that pipeline in place,
let's reattempt this problem.
How do we get community
recommendations
in this modern pipeline?
Well, we now have
the ability to get
core metrics, what our users
are doing, essentially,
in real time.
This is a chart of us rolling
out the recent Reddit redesign.
If you go to
www.reddit.com, you'll
get to see what that looks like.
This is us rolling out
that new system and data
streaming in real time.
This allows us to attempt
a few different approaches.
Our first approach was
to use Jaccard distance.
Sergei will get more
academic about this later,
but Jaccard distance
is simply a way
to calculate the similarity
between two sets.
And this was our first attempt.
If you think about each
subreddit and the people
within it, the people who have
subscribed to that subreddit
as being a set, you can
then use Jaccard distance
to compute the distance
between all of the subreddits
on Reddit.
The problems here are that
we have a lot of subreddits,
about a million subreddits.
This algorithm scales
at O(n) squared.
So humans did the hard part
of essentially whitelisting
the subreddits we thought
would be most interesting,
pruning out the ones
that were very, very
undersubscribed, for example.
Second problem, we have a
ton of default subreddits.
So in the olden days when
you would join Reddit,
there was no onboarding flow.
We would simply subscribe
you to about 20 subreddits.
And this also polluted data.
But we used humans to
clean that up as well.
Problem with that is it still
didn't work really well.
We still got a lot of
mean response behavior
even after doing that tuning.
But we had an insight
that was really important.
Instead of trying to look at
user behavior, what people are
subscribing to and so forth,
why don't we just do something
a little bit different?
The aha moment we had
is that every subreddit
and the comments and the text
that are part of the forum
really can be treated
as a bag of words.
So can we get the subreddits
simply to describe themselves
and what they talk about?
So take all the
corpus of commentary
on a given subreddit, smash
that into a gigantic document,
run doc2vec on it.
And now, we convert
each subreddit
into a 300-dimensional
vector that
represents the semantics of
what that subreddit is about.
And that is the approach
we're using now.
And what this gives
us is we can now
recommend communities by topic.
So if you onboard
into Reddit now,
you'll be given an option to
choose different topics that
you're interested in-- health,
crypto, gaming, et cetera--
and we'll automatically
suggest what
we think are the most
semantically relevant
subreddits to that topic.
So for health, you get
Fitness, Bodybuilding.
For cryptocurrency, you get
BTC and EthTrader, et cetera.
But maybe we can take
that a little further.
What if you already have found
a community that you like?
Can we recommend similar
communities to the one
that you're already
interested in?
So we use a very similar
technique here using that data.
We can get similarity
to Overwatch.
There's Competitive Overwatch.
There's Overwatch University,
which teaches you how to play.
There's Overwatch Memes,
which are essentially
little mini videos of people
playing Overwatch, et cetera.
And then you can
do the same thing.
If you guys are into
machine learning,
you can check out
Learn Machine Learning.
Math, statistics,
data science, all
cover the topic of
machine learning
in some slightly different way.
But maybe we can take
this even further.
What if we could dynamically
compute the main listings
feed for Reddit?
So when you go to reddit.com,
you'll see our popular listing.
If you're signed in, you'll
see our home feed listing.
What if we could make that
more personalized and use
signals such as what you
look at, what you click on,
et cetera?
Reddit's old home
feed algorithm,
if you guys were
wondering how it worked,
was the same ranking
algorithm for 12 years,
hand tuned by our most
brilliant engineer who's
sitting in the fourth row--
[LAUGHS] --hand tuned
algorithm that we
think we could improve on.
So we attempted to use large
scale logistic regression using
time of day subreddits
you're subscribed to,
some interests that we
collect during onboarding,
the device you're on,
mobile or desktop,
and several other signals.
10 terabytes of training
data, 50 million features,
five million parameters.
And we currently
have five versions
of this model in production,
trying to choose the best one,
but we have some very, very
promising early results.
Our early results are we get
a 12% time on site increase
with just our initial attempts.
And this is actually
extremely good.
I'll explain to you
why on the next slide.
This is our Alexa rankings.
You can see Reddit, fourth
largest site on the web.
And the important number here
is the daily time on site,
that column to the far right.
You can see Reddit
is already the most
addictive site on the internet.
People who come to
Reddit stay there longer
than any other site
and we've managed
to increase that
addictiveness even further.
Yeah, we're not letting you go.
Not until the GDP of the
world drops will we be done.
[LAUGHS]
So that's great,
but what's next?
I want to introduce--
Sergei, you jumped at the gun.
You've got to wait in the wings.
I'm cueing you up, man.
Now, all of these improvements
happened in about the last year
and a half.
We're extremely
excited about what
we've been able to accomplish.
Now, what I'm excited
to introduce to you
next is to show off some
work that my colleague
Sergei has done.
And what we view this
partnership with Google
as is what is possible?
What can happen
in the next year?
And he's given us a glimpse
of some amazing results.
So please welcome
Sergei to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
SERGEI SOLOLENKO: Thanks, Nick,
for the wonderful introduction.
So what I wanted to
talk about to you today
was thinking of this concept
of using machine learning
using big data and data
processing, and trying
to come up with some
predictions of user behavior.
Nick talked to you about how, by
building several recommendation
systems, they were able
to drive the time on site
to pretty high values.
So I asked myself
the same question.
What if we could predict
popularity of news articles
on Reddit?
Here's an example
of a news article.
It was written by one of my
colleagues, Martin Gardner.
Some of you might have
heard his session today.
He continues writing about
TensorFlow and deep learning.
So this blog post is
pretty meta because it
is talking about machine
learning and TensorFlow.
And so the question
I ask myself,
if I look at this
blog post and if I
know a couple of
attributes about it,
can I make predictions
about user behavior,
specifically on Reddit?
Now incidentally,
this blog post was
shared four times in four
different communities
by four different people.
So I chose it because it
provided me with some good data
on user behavior, some
real user actions,
and it also was
published back in 2017.
So now, I have about a
year worth of data points
that I can look back and train
my machine learning model on.
So what are these outcomes that
I want to be able to predict?
I want to deal with
predictors and outcomes.
And the outcome for
me is a user action
in my desired Reddit community.
So the first prediction or
the first outcome would be,
what is the subreddit that
this blog post was posted in?
The other predictor--
the other outcome,
sorry, is the person who
decided to share this news
article in the subreddit.
Yet another outcome is
the popularity score.
Those are the
numbers on the left.
And some of the postings achieve
pretty good scores, almost 100,
if not more.
Others only got maybe
a two or a five.
And lastly, one of
the possible outcomes
is the number of
people, users of Reddit,
who come and comment
on the posting
and have a
conversation about it.
OK, so now we
understood the outcomes.
Now, we understood how
users on the Reddit work.
Let's talk about predictors.
What are the possible
predictors for me
to build my machine
learning model on?
One possible predictor is
the author of the blog post.
So the hunch is the person who
writes a news article or blog
post probably has a
community of readers.
And these people
will come to Reddit,
and perhaps there's an overlap
of the readers of the author,
as well as the users of Reddit.
And so these folks
will go and share it
in the community
of their choice.
The other predictor
is the textual content
of the news article.
That's the green
stuff in the middle.
That's the tags, the free
form tags, the topics
the news article is about.
Yet another possible predictor
would be the publication time
and perhaps the place,
the publication domain
where this news
article was posted on.
So I've got four outcomes
that I'm interested in.
I've got four
possible predictors.
Before I jump into talking about
machine learning and TensorFlow
and deep learning, I want
to just quickly cover
the business domain.
It's always good to stop
and think about user actions
and what the business is about.
I tend to think of Reddit
as a huge collection
of threaded conversations.
Someone writes a news article.
That person is typically
outside of Reddit.
This article gets
posted to, I don't know,
the Google Big Data
blog or "New York Times"
or CNN.com or some other
publication domain.
A user on Reddit
picks up this article,
reads it, becomes
interested in the content
and decides to share this
news article in a community
of his or her choice.
Then people on Reddit
come and begin commenting
and you have a conversation
on Reddit about this post.
Across all of these
entities-- and now,
I'm switching back
into architecture stuff
and talking about the
entity relationships.
So across all of these
entities, you always
have the person who
initiated this action.
And you also have some
differences between entities.
For example, the news article
will have textual content.
The blog-- sorry, the Reddit
post will have the subreddit.
And the comments will also
have some textual content.
OK, so now we
understood the business.
Let's go ahead and start
building our deep learning data
set.
And so this is our
first challenge.
And I'm going to talk
about how we solve this.
Ultimately, what
we are trying to do
is to bring two streams of data.
The first stream are
Reddit posts and comments.
The other stream of data are
the news posts or the news
articles.
And so we were lucky that
both of these data streams
are actually available as
public data sets in BigQuery.
The Reddit posts
and comments are
available in a
BigQuery dataset that
is maintained by one of our
developer advocates, Felipe
Hoffa.
So hat tip to him,
thank you, Felipe.
And it draws its data
from a collection
of exports from Reddit that are
operated by Jason Baumgartner.
Thank you, Jason, for
keeping this work up.
Amazing job.
On the new site, we also
have an amazing data set.
And I also want to reach
out to [INAUDIBLE] --who
is maintaining this amazing
database of news articles.
If you wanted to read up on it,
just Google the GDELT project.
The GDELT project contains
pretty much every news article.
I might be outstretching
this, but it
has a very big collection
of news articles
from around the world
in lots of languages.
And it has a lot of metadata
about these news articles,
not just the author of
the article or the time
when it was published, the
URL where it was published,
it also has textual
content as well as topics.
And I'm going to show you how
to use the topics from GDELT
to make predictions.
So we've got these two
amazing BigQuery datasets,
but I also want to do some
additional processing.
It wasn't enough what I
already had in BigQuery.
So I used Cloud Dataflow.
And I'm a product
manager of Cloud Dataflow
and it's always useful to have
access to unlimited processing
power to crunch through
all of this data.
So Dataflow was used
for feature processing.
And again, we stored
everything in BigQuery.
All of our features and
labels are stored in BigQuery.
Great.
So now, we understood
how to build a dataset.
Let's start having some ideas
about possible predictions.
When I like to do
machine learning,
I like to start with a hunch.
And these hunches tend
to be about user behavior
or how the business
is being run.
So my hunch was the contents
of the news article,
as well as where
it was published,
was it the Google's blog post?
Was it maybe a top one site?
Was it kind of a
popular news site?
So these two
predictors are probably
influencing the
outcomes, which are
who will be reading
this news article
and the communities they
will be sharing them.
Well, great.
So out of the four things
on this slide, three of them
are pretty easy to deal
with in machine learning.
The publication domain, the
post submitters and subreddits,
they're pretty much
categorical variables.
You can convert them
easily into numbers.
And once you have numbers,
you can move them into vectors
and you can train your deep
learning models on them.
But the first variable
here, the news content,
that's much more
trickier to deal with.
And it is because
it's free form text.
And although there
are techniques today
to deal with free form
text, they're not perfect.
So these are the
possible techniques
to deal with text and coding.
So I'm going to talk for
the next five minutes
about how we use some
existing encoding techniques
and brought them together
with deep learning,
and achieved pretty
good results.
Nick talked about
using doc2vec--
and it's a variant of word2vec
--to make recommendations
for subreddit similarity.
And it's a great technique.
There's also word2vec
techniques for encoding text
and they have been
used successfully
for basic sentiment analysis
and topic extraction.
But even before deep
learning came on board,
there was a huge
number and huge volume
of research done on natural
language processing.
And I call it pre-deep learning
because word2vec and doc2vec
ended up overshadowing
the previous research done
in that space.
So we actually decided
to use some NLP
techniques to encode our text
and see how well it worked.
And I'm giving you a
little bit of a preview.
It did work.
So here's what we do.
We take a blog
post-- and I'll just
follow the example of
Martin's news article.
So we take this news article and
we extract sentences from text.
And we'll use a Google Cloud
Service, the machine learning
engine, to create syntax trees.
And this is an example of what
is called a dependency tree.
It basically is a
tree of dependencies
between words in a sentence.
There are other variants of
syntax trees, constituency
trees, but pretty much
you can solve the problem
by using what you see
here on the screen.
Now, once we have
syntax trees, we
can do a cool thing
called entity recognition.
I'll give you an example.
In my sample sentence,
deep learning
is a popular approach to
building machine learning
models.
The entity here
is deep learning.
There's another entity
approach and there is yet
another entity model.
In addition to
entity recognition,
you can also do
sentiment analysis.
And nowadays, the
sentiment analysis
can be actually done
on entity level,
not just for the
entire sentence,
but for specific entities.
So now, we know that deep
learning, for example,
has a positive score of 0.9.
This indicates a positive
sentiment towards this entity.
Now, there are other
techniques going
beyond simplistic or simple
binary, positive, negative
classification of sentiment.
And these techniques
were developed
not by computer scientists,
but by psychologists.
In the 1980s, Professor
Plutchik developed
a framework of human emotions.
And he showed that all human
emotions could be classified
into eight basic ones.
For those of you who
can't read the small font,
I'll just list a few of them.
For example, one of the
basic human emotions is joy.
Another one is trust,
yet another is fear.
Then we have disgust,
sadness, and anticipation.
And then he also showed that
every other human emotion
can be composed as a derivative
of these basic eight.
For example, love, the
most human emotion of all,
is actually a combination
of joy and trust.
Now, you can read up and
find some open source
code available on
GitHub by googling
GitHub [INAUDIBLE] opinions.
I'd say Java library that
classifies text and parses text
according to these emotions.
So now, we know that we
can do much more with text.
We can divide it into
chunks and these chunks
contain three things, triplets.
What is the person
thinking about an entity?
What is the opinion of a
person about an entity?
In our sample sentence,
our entity is deep learning
and our opinion is
popular approach.
Now, you might ask
yourself, who is the person?
The person is the person who
wrote the entire article.
So that's how it works.
And once we understood
this, we can
take pretty much
every textual document
and convert it into sequences
of entities followed by opinions
and opinions, and then another
entity and another opinion,
and yet another entity and
opinion, et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera.
So it's going to be a long list.
There's no mistake about that.
But it's a structured list.
It's a list of just
two types, which
also have some attributes.
So it becomes a
structured problem
instead of having
unstructured text.
And so what we know in
the deep learning space,
once you have structure
and sequences,
we can go and encode
them into vectors.
And this is how you solve
the encoding problem
because now, you can much
more nicely encode your text.
Another beauty of
this approach is
that it works with pretty much
every topic, existing topic
classification system.
GDELT is a great example
of how you can easily
take the topics that GDELT
identified and found in text
and use it for
encoding text, and then
using it further
for deep learning.
If you ask yourself,
what are topics,
they're basically just
collections of entities.
Here's an example of what GDELT
thinks about Martin's blog
post.
There are four fields here.
The first one is the
URL of Martin's blog.
So it's kosher.
It's the real thing.
This is exactly what's contained
in the GDELT repository
about Martin's blog post.
And then there are
three additional fields.
There's a theme field.
There's the named entities
field and locations field.
And if you look at
the themes, the things
that GDELT found
in the news article
relate to education,
skills, and jobs.
If you read the article,
you would exactly
match them and concur it is
about skills and learning
TensorFlow, educating yourself.
It is about open source.
And GDELT was also able to find
some named entities, the Google
Cloud Platform developer,
the machine learning entity,
as well as locations.
Martin's blog contained
references to Belgium.
So now, we have this
collection of things.
We have themes.
We have locations.
We have names of
people or things.
And so you throw
this into a bag.
And once you have
a bag, you now know
you can do a bag
of word encodings.
And instead of naming or
calling them bag of words,
you're calling them
bags of things.
And there are various
standard techniques
in deep learning to take
a collection of things
and create a encoding that you
can then further use in machine
learning and deep learning.
And this is how they bring
traditional techniques
for textual analysis with novel
techniques, deep learning.
We are able to use
categorical variables.
And this is, by the way,
a chart of a Keras model.
And I highly recommend using
Keras if you use TensorFlow.
So this is basically
a flow chart
of how entities and variables
are dependent to each other.
So we take some
categorical variables,
such as the publication domain
or the submitter of the Reddit
post, and we can integrate it
together with textual content
through this bag
of things encoding.
And ultimately, we can make
predictions about subreddits.
So our last challenge
in this exercise
was to deal with multiple
outcomes in predictions.
As you've seen, as I
was explaining earlier,
Martin's blog was
actually posted
in four different communities
by four different people.
And we wanted to be
able to make predictions
for multiple outcomes.
I'll just give you a hint.
For those of you who are not
dealing with machine learning
day in day out, there's
a very good technique
and we incorporated
it and embedded it
in our Kaggle kernel.
You can access it later on.
For multi-label classification,
all you have to do
is to tweak your
final output layer
and replace the loss function
and change the output
activation, and do some fancy
encoding of your labels.
Basically use [? and hot ?]
encoding of your labels instead
of one-hot encoding.
So it works.
It can be done.
All right.
So we are two slides
away from the demo.
What I wanted to show
you was concluding,
now we have the dataset.
What did we actually do
to develop the model?
And here, we were
lucky to be able to use
tools such as Kaggle
and Colaboratory.
Kaggle is a great site
for data scientists
to develop, learn, develop new
models, share their models.
One thing that I
liked about Kaggle
was I was able to use GPUs
for training and predictions.
And GPUs really
make the difference.
They make models run 20
times faster than CPUs.
There is another tool available,
and I'll actually be using it
in a demo, called Colaboratory.
Colaboratory is a
new tool by Google.
It's freely available
to everyone.
It's yet another example of
a hosted Jupyter notebook.
By the way, Kaggle is
also a Jupyter notebook.
And if you're not yet
using Jupyter notebooks,
you probably should
be using them.
So both tools are versions
of Jupyter notebooks,
but each of them has
pluses and minuses.
In Colaboratory's
case, what I liked
the most was that I was able
to directly connect to BigQuery
and get my data from BigQuery.
Kaggle also has a
BigQuery connection,
but it's right now limited
to public data sets.
Well, great.
So yep, just one additional
thing that I wanted to mention.
You might have seen me
mentioning a way for us
to do feature pre-processing.
So what we used for
transforming text and finding
emotions in text was a Java
library called Sirocco.
Sirocco is great
because it allows
you to parse text and
find human emotions.
And what we also used
was Cloud Dataflow.
Dataflow was excellent
here because it
allowed me to parallelize
the processing
of these millions of Reddit
posts and news articles.
Without this parallelization,
if I did everything sequential,
it would take me years to
process these huge data sets.
Fortunately, the combination
of this Java library, Sirocco,
together with a distributed
processing framework
allowed me to crunch through
data very, very quickly.
So I wanted to show you a demo.
And the demo will be about
taking Martin's blog post
and doing some predictions.
First off, we'll
see the prediction
that the model, the train model,
does for Martin's blog post.
We'll see whether one
or multiple of the four
actual subreddits are part
of the predicted classes.
And then, we're going to
play a prediction game,
or we're going to
play a scenario game.
We're going to see
if by adding one
additional topic to the
contents of the blog post
would have changed
the possible outcomes.
And the other scenario
that we're going to try
will be what if we took
the same blog post,
but just published
it somewhere else,
not on Google's Big Data
blog, but somewhere else.
All right.
And I'm going to
start by showing you
a query in BigQuery,
which returns
the contents of
the GDELT dataset,
as it relates to Martin's blog.
I'm just specifying
the URL of my blog post
that I'm interested in
and I'm going to run it.
And very quickly,
BigQuery will tell me
what it knows about
Martin's blog post.
I'm actually going to switch
to JSON format and show you
all the fields we've got.
This is just to show
you that the contents
I'm going to be
using for predictions
are pretty much the same
as you've seen on the slide
and as they have it in GDELT.
So we have our themes.
We have our named entities
and we have our locations.
Now, the number that
you see here on screen
are the offsets of the
occurrences of these themes
and locations and names.
We're actually not using
them in the prediction model,
but there's a way
for using them,
especially if you wanted
to use a sequence encoding
and use CNNs or RNNs.
We're not going to do it today,
but there's some use for it
as well.
So I'm to switch
to Colaboratory.
And what it shows you
is my Jupyter notebook
and a bunch of cells here
that I probably don't need.
So let me start with
the one that actually
is important for the demo.
So for those of you who
use Jupyter notebooks,
you're familiar with the
concept of code being in a cell
and then being able
to run the cell
and get output of your code.
For those of you who
don't, that's basically
what's going to happen.
I have some Python code in each
of the cells of this notebook
and I'm going to
run these cells.
I'm going to explain what
they do and then run them
and you'll see the outputs.
In this particular
cell, what I have here
are all of the instructions
to build my model
and train it on my test data.
This is the variable
that will hold the model,
and inputs into this model
will be two features.
I will use the encoded
entities from GDELT,
and I will use the publication
domain of news articles.
My outputs will be subreddits.
That's my prediction.
That's my label class.
Before the demo, I want to
[INAUDIBLE] the training.
So I'm going to skip this step.
And sort of for
all of the comments
here, I'm just going to
explain what's happening here.
In the next cell, I have
my first prediction.
So I wanted to show you what
the predicted probabilities are
of our model for Martin's blog
post without any modifications.
So I just simply copied and
created two variables here,
which contain the
contents of the blog post.
Here are my GDELT
entities and here
is the publication domain
of that news article.
In the next couple of lines,
I'm going to run my encoding.
And then I'm going to call
the most important function
here in the entire cell,
which is the prediction.
And lastly, after
doing the prediction,
I'm going to print
out the probabilities
that this model created.
So let me run it.
All right.
So here's what the
model anticipates.
It predicts a pretty
high probability
for Martin's blog post to
be shared on the Futurology
subreddit, as well as on
the Technology subreddit
and the Hacker News subreddit.
And if you paid
attention, Hacker News
was actually one
of the predicted--
actually, one of the actual
subreddits this news article
was shared in.
If you scroll down
in the list, you
will also see the
second subreddit,
which this news
article was posted on,
the Artificial subreddit.
Now, you have to
scroll for a long time
until you hit the
third predicted class.
It is in the list of
predicted classes.
Doesn't even fit the top 100.
It does happen.
You can't always
put human behavior
in a mathematical model.
But having two out
of four, actually
three out of four among the top
predicted classes is not bad.
So here's my third subreddit,
which Reddit users actually
did post this blog post to.
And it's a top 111th prediction.
Great.
So now, we have techniques
for multi-label predictions.
And sometimes, you
get lots of hits.
Sometimes you get maybe half
of the possible outcomes.
But having two out of
four is not a bad thing.
So now, let's play
a prediction game.
In my next scenario, I want to
ask Google or TensorFlow, what
happened if I discuss just one
additional topic in my model?
So the blog post today is about
deep learning and TensorFlow.
What if we discussed just
one additional topic here?
I'm going to take 2,000 entities
from my list, my dictionary
of entities, and I'm going
to go through each of them
and just compose a new
text of the blog post,
run it through encoding, and
pick the top 10 predictions.
And here are the predictions.
Let's just go through
a couple of them.
Turns out if Martin,
the author of the blog,
wrote a little bit
about hydroenergy
and hydroelectricity,
he would have,
actually, an even higher
chance of being shared
in the Technology subreddit.
But the top five subreddits
would stay relatively the same.
It would still be Hacker News.
It would be Apple.
It would be Futurology
and the CIDJ--
I'm actually not even sure
what the subreddit is about.
Now, let's look at
another prediction.
What if Martin wrote
about Elon Musk?
It looks like writing about
Elon almost guarantees you
good coverage in Reddit.
The probability of
that new blog post
that has a mentioning
of Elon Musk
drives your
predicted probability
of being shared in
Futurology pretty high.
And for the other classes,
the predicted subreddits
stay relatively the same.
They do vary in probabilities.
You might get a bit
higher probability
for some of the classes.
But if you track what's at
the bottom of this chart,
you see the same
values again and again.
OK, so this gives us something.
Now, we have a tool
to be able to predict
hypothetical scenarios
where we just
add yet additional topic to
discuss in our blog post,
and we have immediate
outcomes for possible user
behavior on Reddit.
The other scenario that
I wanted to show you was,
what if we took this blog
post, made no changes
to the contents, but just
published it somewhere else?
So this code goes
through every publication
domain known to the model
and it runs predictions.
And again, it picks the
top 10 predictions based
on the sum of probabilities.
That's how they're being ranked.
OK, so let's see the outcomes.
It looks like if we
published Martin's blog
post on aljazeera.com,
we would pretty much
be guaranteed a share or a post
on the "Al Jazeera" subreddit.
So the probability
is almost 86%,
as well as in the [? Villas ?]
7737 news subreddit.
For those of you who don't
know, "Al Jazeera" actually
has a news bot that
republishes content that
was published on aljazeera.com.
So yeah, it's kind
of an obvious thing.
If you publish anything
on aljazeera.com,
it will get
automatically reposted.
But for some other publication
domains, it's not as obvious.
For example, if you take
"Scientific American,"
then you stand a
pretty good chance
of being republished or reposted
in the Raytheon subreddit.
What are the other subreddits?
Well, it's the usual suspects.
It's technology and
futurology, but they have
all different probabilities.
If you have the leverage
of publishing your content
in different places, now you
can make decisions on, OK,
I want to go over this
publisher or maybe perhaps
another publisher.
Interestingly, I ran through
the test samples before.
If you ended up getting
published on MIT's "Technology
Review," you would actually
stand a pretty good chance
of being republished
in Artificial, which
was one of the actual subreddits
where this blog post was
published on.
Well, great.
So we've seen a
couple of examples
of how we can use machine
learning to make predictions
for hypothetical scenarios.
And for those of you in
the publishing industry
or people who
write blog posts, I
hope this was pretty convincing
methodology and tooling
for making decisions,
what to write about,
and where to publish.
To summarize, talking about
accuracy of our models.
We tried a bunch of things.
And the things that did work
I talked to you about today,
but let me summarize
the path to success.
When we started with just
textual content-- and these
are two models over here.
When we only use textual
content of news articles,
we achieve pretty low results.
Our accuracy was in
the 55, 57% range.
Only when we added the
publication domain to the mix,
when we had two variables,
domain and the text,
did we ended up pushing and
moving towards the 80% range.
Now, we also tried
out a model where
we added the
submitter to the mix
and made it one
of the predictors.
You cannot use the last model
for predicting future based
on just the news article,
but you can do pretty amazing
anomaly detection things.
So for example, if you observe
user behavior on Reddit
and it doesn't match this
model, then perhaps something
interesting is going on.
Maybe a bot is beginning
posting or maybe a user account
was taken over by someone else.
We also did some predictions
for popularity score.
And some of the
earlier predictions
we've done on models
we built to try
to do regression and
predict a number, 55,073
as the score of a news article.
Those didn't really converge
and we didn't really
have good outcomes there.
But once we switched to
classification and bent
our scores into six
distinct classes,
we were able to achieve
pretty good results.
And the confusion matrix
on, I guess, your right,
shows you a nice
diagonal placement
of predictions and true labels.
So I wanted to wrap up and just
summarize what we've seen today
and what we talked about today.
We hope that Nick's
and my stories
were able to convince you that
being able to predict user
behavior can have significant
impact on the outcome
of your business.
Reddit was able to drive
the time on site higher.
You can use, for example, the
techniques you've seen today
to better place the content in
different publication domains
or perhaps choose different
topics you want to write about.
These techniques are not
unique to social media.
You can apply them in
pretty much every industry.
We've seen today how text
encoding and multi-label
classification
and bags of things
can help you, even if you are,
perhaps, a car manufacturer
or IoT device supplier
or a cloud provider,
to build pretty sophisticated
and powerful machine learning
models.
There's a great
collection of tools
here on the slide, BigQuery,
Cloud Dataflow, Kaggle,
and Colab,
TensorFlow, obviously.
I also wanted to give
you a couple of links
for all of the code
that we used today
for the predictions
and sampling.
There are kernels on Kaggle.
There's code on GitHub.
I want to give a shout out
to Kalev from GDELT project.
Without his support,
this would not happen.
The same goes to Jason
Baumgartner from Pushshift.io.
Without his data, again,
this would not have happened,
as well as Felipe Hoffa.
And lastly, if you
want to, if you're
interested in machine learning
and want to learn more,
feel free to check out
Reddit's subreddit.
Hopefully, this will
be the community
that you will decide on within
five minutes instead of taking
four years, as Nick had.
But it's a great community
of learning resources.
Thank you very
much, and we will be
happy to take your
questions after the session.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]